-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Oh, man.
I love it, love it.
-I appreciate this.
The last time we saw each other,
we were at
an Islanders playoff game.
-Yes, we were.
-We were in the --
one of the last games in --
-At the Nassau Coliseum.
-The Barn.
-The old Barn, the old Barn.
-We got up -- we're up in --
-Visual aids.
-Yeah, we were up
on the Jumbotron together.
-Yes, we were.
-Here's us going crazy.
-There we are.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Little --
Little to no enthusiasm.
-Yeah, we went beyond crazy
trying to get the --
-That energy in that room
is just amazing.
Almost as good as it is
right here tonight.
-You feeling that?
You're know what I'm saying?
It's like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
When it's rockin'...
When it -- it's --
When you have a great crowd
and it's rockin',
there's no way to describe it.
It -- it was like --
It was an amazing experience.
I just loved --
Singing the national anthem...
-Yes.
And everyone sang it along.
It was just amazing.
-Everyone sang it so loud
that the girl singing
put the mic down.
-She dropped the mic.
-Well, she came back for
"of the free."
-Yeah.
It's the best.
-She didn't count on 15,000 --
-I got goose bumps.
-It was amazing.
-But I hope I didn't bother you
too much, because I kept
talking to you the whole game
because I was so excited.
Because I didn't --
We didn't know
we were gonna go together.
-No, no.
I didn't -- you surprised me.
I was there with my son.
It was awesome.
And we just, you know --
-I kept asking you --
-It was such an exciting time,
because the team
has just come into its own.
They were having
a great playoff run.
They've won every -- almost
every game in the playoff run
they won,
except for this game, Jimmy.
I'm not judging, man.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not judging.
But I will say one thing
about going to a hockey game
with Jimmy Fallon.
He stayed for every second.
The ultimate enthusiastic,
optimistic --
even when I knew this game was
not going to happen for my team,
he was like, "We got this!
We got this!"
[ Laughter ]
-"Yeah, come on!
We gotta have faith!"
-We really had a great time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love the stories.
I love your son.
Say hi to Daniel for me.
-I will.
-But you were telling me stories
about how your dad
used to bring you there.
-My mom and dad, we used to go
to those games when I was a kid.
My childhood
was in that building.
So to get to share that with
my -- my kid, it was awesome.
-But you were pointing out
seats where you used to sit.
-Yeah, yeah. "I sat there
when they won the Stanley Cup.
And I sat there
when they lost 12 in a row."
-It was the perfect person
to sit next to.
And I was bothered --
I was so intrigued by you,
I was like, "Wait, wait, wait.
So tell me what --
-"The game, it's over there."
-"Yeah, let's watch --
focus on the playoffs.
Yeah."
But you know what was great,
is they love you so much there.
And I'll tell you this.
It was such a cool experience
because I'm -- you know when you
go to a stadium or you go to
an event and they go,
"Let's get loud,"
and then, "Let's get louder."
You know?
And they have the meter
on the Jumbotron?
Even louder than loudest is you.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
And they were doing,
"Wax on, playoffs,"
is what they were saying.
-And when it got to the thing,
like, "Aah!"
we're all screaming,
and then it went to you.
And I go, "Wait. What?
You're louder?"
and then they cut to you.
And -- And there was like --
[ Screaming ]
And people were freaking out.
And they saw
where we were sitting.
It was --
It was just an awesome --
-It was.
-I found something that is --
I don't know.
I think it's pretty rare.
But this is --
NHL, the Islanders
actually made your --
you got your own hockey card.
Look at this.
This is -- the Islanders made --
This is it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was -- That was around --
That was like 1991.
And "My Cousin Vinny"
had just come out at that time.
And they were -- the NHL --
it was the 75th year
of the National Hockey League,
so they were
going to different teams,
find celebrity captains,
and I got -- you know, that's --
I mean, I got a hockey card.
I mean, who else?
It was, like,
John Goodman with St. Louis.
-Wow.
-And Mr. Rogers,
Pittsburgh Penguins.
Who knew?
-Mr. Rogers.
Yeah, Pittsburgh.
Yeah, absolutely.
-It was -- It was awesome.
-I mean, is this --
-I can't believe you found that.
I mean, nothing's safe.
Nothing is safe.
-No, nothing's safe.
No, I have everything, yeah.
Do you have one of these?
-I -- I do.
I do.
-Yeah. All right, good.
So you can keep that one.
-Okay, good.
I want -- I will keep it
in mint condition.
-In mint condition, right.
I love that you put
the gloves on, too,
which makes me laugh.
-Yeah, well, I --
[ Laughter ]
-Like, what?
For the photo shoot?
-I don't know what that was.
It had to be my choice.
Maybe it was me
trying to be badass.
[ Laughter ]
-You're like, "I'm gonna
do something that no other
fan -- superfan will do."
Yeah.
-Right.
-I want to congratulate you
on "Cobra Kai," by the way.
-Thanks, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Season four of "Cobra Kai" now.
Within days,
it became the number-one
most watched show globally
on Netflix.
-Amazing.
-Number one!
-Thank you!
-And last week, "Cobra Kai"
scored a big SAG nomination
for Outstanding
Action Performance.
-Oh, the stunt --
our stunt team's amazing.
Amazing.
-Dude -- do you --
But you must get in there.
I see you.
-I do get in there.
-Yeah.
-I do.
And we all work very, very hard.
We have a lot of studly, young,
amazing athletic cast members.
So guys like William Zabka
and myself need to --
need to keep up.
[ Laughter ]
And we do.
We do.
They --
You know, it's --
But, you know, I could pull,
like, my ass muscle, like,
with one wrong kick
without stretching.
It's the stretching.
It's all about stretching.
-No, it is all about stretching.
Oh, my gosh.
-Always about stretching.
But we --
You know, but what happens now,
Jimmy, is I give --
I give, like -- like, an injury
report to the stunt team.
I mean, this is something
that I've done.
I sort of feel like an NFL coach
on a Monday morning
after Sunday.
saying like,
"Macchio is day-to-day
with a right hamstring pull."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, like, "All right,
gather around, everybody."
Yeah.
-He can turn 30% to the right.
But the left side, can't let --
-Can't do it.
-And they actually tailor
the fight scenes to my strengths
and make me look great,
so that's how we do it.
-They're like, "All right, just
use your left arm in this one."
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
-I saw that this --
There's always surprises
and brand-new characters
coming in every episode.
So if you haven't seen
"Cobra Kai,"
you can start season one.
You'll get it.
You'll understand,
but you'll be like, "What?
Do you -- and every -- yeah.
But this season, your actual,
real-life daughter, Julia,
is on the show with you.
-Yes, she is.
-Not playing your daughter.
-No.
-But still, there she is there.
-Oh, that was us
in the dressing room.
Yes, yes.
This was after we --
-How great is that?
-That's Julia.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And with -- with respect
to the great Pat Morita.
-Pat Morita.
-Mr. Miyagi, you know?
-Yeah, she's wearing
a Miyagi T-shirt.
I love that.
-Yeah. She --
She knocked it out of the park.
The writers of the show
came up with a character
for her that --
She's active, sings and dances.
And a triple threat.
-Wow!
-And she's -- she's awesome.
-Wonder where she got that from.
-Yeah, no.
-Yeah, exactly right.
-I'd say it skips a generation.
She has it.
I'm working on it.
-Yeah, right.
-And she --
You know, I was nervous.
You know, your own kid.
-Of course.
-And listen, I went on the show,
but she --
they wrote her this great role,
and she gets to question
my parenting skills,
which was kind of meta
to have my own kid
asking me why I'm failing
as a parent.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
-It was a lot of fun.
-Speaking of the writing,
I should say the writing
is fantastic on this show.
-They are terrific.
-Kudos to those writers.
-Thanks.
-It's funny, it's smart,
it's interesting.
I go -- and it's almost like
it's never-ending.
I mean, this is just getting
bigger and bigger.
So it's like a -- you're
creating a whole universe.
-Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Listen, Jon, Josh and Hayden
are the main creators
of the show
and the entire writing staff.
These guys,
they are truly the fans
that are writing the show
for the fans.
So they -- they have their --
You know,
they have their big canvas
and all the paints up there.
And they just --
It's now growing.
The cast is -- is growing,
getting deeper, more --
The curves and turns
and twists they're taking.
You know, it has become --
You say that it -- it's --
It could go
so many different places.
It's becoming the sort of
Karate Kid Cinematic Universe
is what we talk about.
-Yeah, it is.
-You know, like Marvel.
Like, I mean,
we could do prequels,
we could do movies.
Maybe we'll do a spinoff
in this direction.
-Yeah, they can.
-I don't know where it's going.
-It's just getting
bigger and bigger,
and it's all great and all fun,
and you go --
-It's a lot of fun.
-And good little nods
to the movie.
And all the movies.
-Mm-hmm.
-And it's just --
It's well done.
And everyone's great.
Congrats on everything, buddy.
-Thank you.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ralph Macchio
and William Zabka
in "Cobra Kai."
Take a look at this.
-That's it.
Balance good.
Karate kick.
Everything --
-[ Grunts ]
-This thing isn't even level.
-Or maybe you have a little
imbalance inside of you.
-I still don't see me using
any of this in a real fight.
-I've been trying to tell you.
Miyagi-do is not about fighting.
You know what Mr. Miyagi said
was the best defense
in all of karate?
-High outside block
against an axe kick?
-The best defense
is "no be there."
-You mean, "Don't be there"?
Guy teaches you centuries
of his ancient family karate
and you can't help him
with his English?
-Don't even go there with me,
Johnny.
-All right, are we done,
or do I have to sit in here
and freeze my [bleep] off
to find inner peace?
-No.
We're done.
-Yeah, that's it right there.
"Yeah, we're done."
-"We're done."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ralph Macchio, everybody,
from the New York Islanders.
-[ Laughs ]
-"Cobra Kai" season four
is streaming now on Netflix.